Schon heute könnten wir mit herkömmlichen
Autos komplett klimaneutral fahren.
E-Fuel soll das möglich machen.
Das heißt Benzin, das mittels Elektrizität
(E) aus Wasser und CO2 gewonnen wird.
Ist das DIE Lösung um den Klimawandel aufzuhalten?
Es gibt einen Haken.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Es könnte alles so einfach sein.
Mittels Strom aus Wasser per Elektrolyse Wasserstoff
gewinnen und CO2 aus der Atmosphäre filtern
und fertig ist der Klimaneutrale Treibstoff,
wenn der Strom aus regenerativen Energien
kommt.
Und E-Fuels haben einen riesigen Vorteil.
es werden keine Ladesäulen benötigt, keine
Elektroautos und die alten Fahrzeuge können
weiter benutzt werden.
Satt Millionen neue Elektrofahrzeuge zu verkaufen
ginge das ohne eine solche Investition.
Aber warum kann man diese Treibstoffe nicht
kaufen?
Und warum kommen sie in der Diskussion über
den Klimawandel praktisch nicht vor?
Im gegenteil: Nahezu alle Umweltschutzorganisationen
verdammen sie.
Es ist die Effizienz.
Ein Elektroauto verbraucht je nach Größe
etwa 15 Kilowattstunden auf 100 Kilometer.
Schon bei mit Wasserstoff betriebenen Brennstoffzellenfahrzeugen
sinkt die Effizienz deutlich.
Der Wasserstoff muss erst per Elektrolyse
also mit elektrischem Strom aus Wasser gewonnen
werden.
Das ist mit Verlusten behaftet.
Ein Wasserstoffauto verbraucht deshalb das
doppelte eines Elektroautos, rund 30 Kilowattstunden
auf 100 Kilometer und beim E-Fuel wird es
nahezu desaströs.
Bei der Produktion und im Motor entstehen
Verluste, die den Verbrauch auf mehr als 100
Kilowattstunden schnellen lassen, das siebenfache
eines Elektroautos.
Letztendlich Wahnsinn und der Grund für die
große Ablehnung.
Aber mit was sollen Flugzeuge und Schiffe
angetrieben werden.
Hier könnten Hybridantriebe mit E-Fuels die
Lösung sein.
Beim Flugzeug könnten mit E-Fuels angetriebene
Düsen den Vortrieb leisten, wozu heute elektrisch
angetriebene Düsen einfach nicht in der Lage
wären.
Während des Langstreckenfluges könnte das
Flugzeug elektrisch auf Reisegeschwindigkeit
gehalten werden.
Die Luft ist dünn in der Reise-Flughöhe
und damit der Luftwiderstand gering.
Und auch bei Schiffen könnte das die Lösung
sei, bevor Batterien mit höherer Energiedichte
zur Verfügung stehen.
Und die großen Ölkonzerne arbeiten deshalb
an der produktion solcher Treibstoffe.
Sie haben schließlich die Expertise für
Brennstoffe.
Shell hat gerade mit dem Bau einer Elektrolyseanlage
in Nordrhein-Westfalen begonnen.
Die Lufthansa hat in Schleswig-Holstein mit
der Produktion von Klimaneutralem Kerosin
begonnen.
Der Fughafen Rotterdam arbeitet an der Entwicklung
einer Fabrik für E-Fueks.
Und Audi hat sich mit Energieversorgern und
Ölkonzernen zusammengetan um E-Fuels zu produzieren.
Allerdings bleibt die Kritik.
Greenpeace hält den Weg generell für falsch.
Allerdings gibt es eine Nische, die E-Fuels
sehr interessant machen.
Überschüssiger Strom.
An einem windreichen Tag müssen Windkraftanlagen
vom Netz genommen werden.
Ihr Strom ist einfach zuviel und wird nicht
gebraucht.
An einem solchen Tag könnte diese Energie
genutzt werden um E-Fuels zu produzieren.
Damit könnte überschüssiger Strom gespeichert
werden und klimaneutral in Verbrennungsmotoren
verbrannt werden.
Roland Dittmeyer ist Professor am Karlsruher
Institut für Technologie KIT.
Er hatte die Idee für Container-große Produktionsanlagen.
Sie können einfach neben Windräder gestelt
werden und produzieren dann Treibstoff, wenn
zu viel Wind weht.
Sein Kollege Tim Böltken baut sie mit seiner
Firma Ineratec und man kann sie jetzt schon
kaufen.
Und das ist noch nicht alles.
Noch mehr Infos zum Thema gibt es auf Clixoom
nature, dem neuen Kanal mit Videos zu Natur
und Umwelt.
Anklicken, anschauen und abonnieren.
Ich freue mich mit euch dort etwas gegen den
Kimawandel und für eine bessere Umwelt tun
zu können.
Bis dann, beibt dran!